「い～つの話だっただろうか」 「俺が確か～～～、
まだyoutubeで登録者数がたぶんほんと
５万とか、６万いや１０万くらいだったかな。
それくらいだった時に、もやし男と呼ばれ続けて
おり、その時私はもやし男と呼ばれるのが嫌で
キング牛丼というものを食べた。」「キング牛丼とはすき家に売っている
隠しメニューのこと。」「すき家のメニューにあるサイズの中では
最大のメガ牛丼の！」
「２個分のサイズ～～～(ドヤッ)」
「キング牛丼というものがございます！」「僕最近撮影で、
牛丼を食べる機会が色々あったんですけども」
「わたくし～マジで牛丼を食べるのが早くなっております（自慢）」
「２５年間
生きてきた中で僕の食（つまり食欲）が
細かった時期とか細いしてかガリガリそもそも、まｗｗ
食べないみたいなイメージ、があったと思うんですけどそれを払拭するくらい、最近すごい肉」
「牛丼を食べるスピードが速いなぜかというと去年肉を禁止していたから
その反動もあって肉に対するモチベーション。」「食べたいという
ハングリー精神が人（よりも）365倍
高いんですよ！！！」「１年間肉食って
ないから～んも～肉を食べれることにすんごい！」
「ありがたみ，感謝，リスペクト精神がすごい」
「かつ最近よく食うんで、で最近実はキング牛丼
お店で、ぱあ～て食ってみたんですけどもちょっとなんか
ぺちゃくちゃ喋りながらへへ~~wwってやったら、
１０分で食べれました（ドヤッ）。やばくないですか！キング牛丼１０分ですよ～（2度目の自慢！）」
「たぶんね～そこそこね早いと思うんですよ～。」「僕のタイム
計る前に色んなyoutuberとか過去の僕のタイムとかをちょっと
調べていましょう～！」
「ｗｗ」
「あｗそうなんだｗえ～っと」「僕が2014年に
食べた時2014年3月に、食べたときは、
え～と120分。約120分かかつております～～。」
「ま～それくらいですよｗ細かったんで遅いんです。」「そしてリベンジ
2016年の10月に食べたときは約20分
かかっております」
「あ、じゃ2年ごとにやってるのかな？」「2010年が120分。2016年が20分。」
「そして今から2019年バージョンを出します！（イエーーイ）」
「で他のyoutuberの記録を見ると」「ンダホが
え～12分45秒
お～まあまあ」「恭ちゃんがリタイア。」
「あれでリタイアか。」ぷぷぷｗｗ（余裕なのに）
「プリッとチャンネル9分56秒。お～～～まあまあ」
「ボンボンTVりっちゃんとえっちゃん
2人で14分36秒」
「すするTV、37分9秒。あれじゃ食べれん。すすることしかできん。」
「キャラダイスTVアドゥが6分30秒。
タカタが18分18秒。」「誰かわからん。」「というわけでパッと見た感じ
youtuber最速が大体6分30秒」
「え~（驚愕）そんなことできるのｗ」
「まあいいでしょう～。」「今日のわたくしは気合が違います。」「自己ベスト記録
20分を超えるのは当たり前として可能であればyoutuberで
1番早くキング牛丼を食べ切りたい」
はじめん「というわけで、１人で食べていてもこうなんか記録が伸びなさそうなんで
ライバルを用意しました。」トミー「はい！水溜りボンドのトミーです。よろしく。」
はじめん「トミーはちなみにキング牛丼食べたことありますか？」
トミー「たぶんないと思います」
はじめん（マジか ）
トミー「あれっ？。無いと思います」
トミー「あるんですかね？」はじめん「あります」トミー「ありますね。すいません。ありました」
トミー「ありました」はじめん「無いです」トミー「すみません。ないで～す」
はじめん「隣にトミーを置いといてキング牛丼を食うと
さらにタイムが進むんじゃないか。ペースメーカーとして（自分は何を言ってるんだ？）ちょっとわたくしの隣で食べて
いただけると、助かります。」はじめん「というわけでyoutuberで1番
キング牛丼（を食べるの）が早い男に俺はなる。」
トミー「なりましょう！」はじめん「もう元気になったんで 」トミー「すみません」
はじめん「キング牛丼下さい。」店員「キング牛丼ください」はじめん「はい」
はじめん「では！トミーの協力を受けて」
トミー「はい。すいませんよろしくお願いします。」はじめ「キング牛丼のタイムアタック」はじめ「とりあえず、2010 年と2016年の
僕は抜きたいです。」
トミー「ちょっと目標下げてません？」スタッフ「では、いきます！用意
スタート！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！」
はじめん＆トミー「頂きます」
トミー「こんな量いけるのかな？」
早送り中
トミー（あっつ）
はじめん「あ、熱い熱い熱い」
トミー「熱いですね」
（また）早送り中
んん！！ん（えっ！？）
ん！（なんだとトミー）
はじめん（ヤバッ！！）
トミー「若手の根性です」
はじめん（マジか！！）
はじめん「終わり？」トミー「ごちそう様です！！！」
はじめん「3分43秒」
トミー「あざす！」はじめん「まってが乱れる乱れる、トミーは関係ない」
はじめん「見るな見るな」
トミー「めちゃくちゃ苦しいです。」
（また×2）早送り中
トミー「はははははは～すいません。ちょっとｗ」はじめん「やばいよ～ 」
トミー（ちょっと調子に乗りすぎたかもしれません）
（また×3）早送り中
トミー「大丈夫ですか？」
（また×4）早送り中
トミー「あああ、すいません」
はじめん（ペシッ）
（また×5）早送り中
トミー「めちゃくちゃ」
トミー「僕のせいでよくわかんない事になってる」
トミー「（はじめんの結果）8分35秒」
トミー「めっちゃ早いんすけど、、、」
トミー「その俺めちゃくちゃややこしな」
はじめん「変」
見てくれてありがとう。続きがまだあるよ
また見てね(^O^)/
はじめん「8分30秒はめちゃくちゃ早いです」
はじめん「い～やたぶん僕かすんでますけど僕も相当早いです」
トミー「いやそうとうに早いですよ。ほんとに」
はじめん「やばい」
トミー（僕は3、、、3分半とかですか？）
トミー「3分」スタッフ「3分43秒」トミー「あ、43」
はじめん「たぶん」
なかなかだと思うよ。
トミー（そのはじめさんのチャンネルだ～～～ていう）
はじめん「モチべが上がっ上がっちゃったんだ」
トミー「めちゃくちゃ高かったです！」はじめん「8分35もなかなか早いんで」
はじめん「あの～是非腕に自信がある方は挑戦してみてはいかがでしょう」
はじめん（あ～くそ～勝てん）　終わり